normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government you've
got a guy who's got higher Name ID than
almost anyone in the entire world
someone who's by far the most famous
conservative on the face of the planet
so explain to me then by when given all
that and oh by the way um the majority
of the party cuz remember you run in the
party then you run in the general right
you have it's one then the other it's
not straight to General so they keep
making these weird general election aru
arguments which are completely baseless
by the way that only Ronda centus can
win the general which there's just no
evidence well he can't win the general
if he can't win the nomination but most
I'm not going to say half the majority
of the party feels that Donald Trump
actually won the 2020 election they feel
that January 6 was about protesting a
stolen election and they want Trump to
go back and finish the job that's a
really easy sell for a political
candidate if you've got someone who's
arguing against that uh it it just comes
across as really self-centered it comes
across as really selfish and quite
frankly it comes across as politically
stupid because you could have he could
have gone and I said this so many times
behind the scenes all you had to do was
say uh Donald Trump has unfinished
business and I'm going to be supporting
him in
2024 then regardless of what happened in
that election all of Maga would remember
that Dan sanis had stood by the man who
put him in the governor's mansion of
Florida instead of running this insane
betrayal of a backstabbing raising
millions of dollars laundering it
through the Republican Governor's
Association putting it then into the
governor's race in Florida which was a
non-competitive race taking those
millions of dollars away from
competitive races all around the country
Democrats win then they blame that on
Donald Trump then he rolls that same
money which again which was supposed to
go to gubernatorial candidates into his
own presidential campaign this is where
Never Back Down starts because they roll
that over into Federal you can't get it
go one to one but they brought most of
it over the bulk of it and then claims
all the time that he's just on a
national book tour he's not really
running was weird that really pissed me
off too and and so it's it's and and all
the while remember you chose this okay
you all chose this you could have sat
back and been handed the Baton the
mantle of Maga as the air parent and
literally walked into the White House in
2028 obvious there was someone in his
ear saying you don't want to be
tarnished with that brush right there
was someone who talked him out of think
seeing Trump and the potential role as
an air parent as a good thing look I I
just i e either look you you can say
what you want but at the end of the day
I mean he's his own man but wouldn't
that be what the implication was because
they had a somewhat positive
relationship at one point and then it
was like well you could run for
president now and challenge Trump or
could wait four years and do it then
someone had to convince him that the
timing was right now to me it seems like
the argument must have been you don't
want to be branded with the mega mantle
but who what argument is that because we
know the core of the Republican voters
are Mega they do support Donald Trump
the thing that gets me is that they
don't recognize it as a betrayal they
think that it's just some sort of oh
it's just a free for-all and you know so
anyone can run for president and it's
fine excuse me EXC that you were a
backbench congressman that no can you
don't even talk about your own
accomplishments from when you were in
the house because you don't have any he
was another guy at dinner when we were
at Trump Tower or Trump Hotel in DC and
oh by the way that's right you were
eating dinner out of a building on the
front of it was the name of the man that
gave you the ability because you know
you were going to run again for Senate
against Marco Rubio but then Marco said
that he was going to come back in so you
cucked out of that and said well what am
I going to do what am I going to do and
then oh cuz you didn't want to run
against Lil Marco so then you said all
right well I've got this infrastructure
Statewide maybe I can roll that into a
governor's race so you went and did that
and you were about to lose to Adam putam
and then you came to Trump and then you
begged and begged and Begg and don't
even did they say I didn't do that yes
he did he did yeah he went and begged
for the endorsement and Trump was going
to get behind putham because everybody
thought that putham was going to get
going to be the guy I like fine we
wanted a governor who could win and
remember Florida was a a 50-50 State
back then uh Andrew Gillum right the you
know the the coke addled sex fiend
um came within that's right that was a
crazy story they found the hotel room
came within just a few votes like like
less than a percentage of of becoming
the governor of Florida and if it was
only for Donald Trump and only for the
Maga Grassroots who went down there
after the election using the slogan and
I'm just going to say it Tim I'm going
to say it hash stop the steal thought
you gonna say something else hash stop
the steel to fight for Ronda santis uh
that that put that over and Juan Broward
County and there's no recognition of any
of that work there's no recognition of
those rallies there's no recognition or
even thanks for putting you there it's
I'm going to run against you because I
think I'm better and now yes I'm sure
there are people who you know found some
way to you know use Verbal Judo to be
able to say that it's not betrayal but
it is and I'm sorry it just is see that
makes me want to know who who did it
like what part of the Republican donor
class or who what political operative
was like this is a great idea we should
do it I wish that we could have a name
because that would be interesting to
know who Twisted one political career
because you know Donald Trump has a lot
to offer the country he could only be
president for four more years who is
actually there is a darker potential
read on that um you know because you
know we were just talking about
Kissinger right so who would want to
talk someone into destroying their own
political future by convincing them to
do a political suicide run against the
most famous conservative in a generation
somebody who wants the the Neo livs and
the neocons to regain power anding push
them all out right so you incite a Maga
Civil War yep which is exactly what
happens what happened you you get you
pit Maga against each other you split
them down the middle and to be fair like
I I actually expected Dan santis to run
like a real campaign I have no idea he
did not run a real campaign it was so
bizarre I mean there are ways you can
drop bombs on Trump from the right but
they just they just never did it never
came it was this weird like insinuation
kind of thing and then you know they've
kind of started to now but the the
attacks are like really weird and
confusing and very like yeah they said
he had a foot fetish like right that
stuff is weird too it doesn't make this
is the opposite of me magic so so it's a
great examp run against his policies
it's a great example of so you were
talking about me magic before and by the
way there's a whole other Theory I have
and maybe it's more of a third hour
theory that um the lockdowns in 2020
were actually designed to prevent Mee
Magic from seeping back into reality
so me magic was kept on lock down
because remember all of this remember
folks remember never lose sight of the
prize we are in a time
traveler Chrono war with the globalists
that's what's really going on right now
what do you mean well Steve third hour
third hour Steve Bannon is uh Baron from
the future who's been sent back to guide
his father um there's a height you know
differential with the with the time
space continuum no it's you know when
you get older you get shorter Steve Ben
actually pretty tall
uh he's taller than average yeah he's
not
71 younger form but I'm not saying like
he's not like 5'6 57 no no no no no but
I mean to be fair I mean Bar's like
seven feet tall see the but yeah St
Baron is enormous that's that's what I'm
trying to say yeah um well but but you
but so to to my point though is is that
um we never get the Civil War so the
Civil War you know it starts but then it
stops uh they have these completely St
range attacks on him they go and and
make these absolutely boneheaded
political decisions like like agreeing
to debate a guy who's not even running
for president right what's up with that
that's him which which only has upside
for Nome right there's no there's no
upside for there's no upside for if he
loses he look really bad and if he wins
like he's supposed to it doesn't matter
supposed to and somebody who's not
running right getting him to agree was
all all Newsome needed so so now
suddenly Newsome's got people talking
about him as a presidential candidate
which is which plays into his interests
in the Democrat Shadow primary that's
going on right now because they want
Biden to drop out they want him to do
this Jill won't let it happen because I
mean man it was rough dude you and you
could see Biden looking at like giving
the side eye to Jimmy Carter right at
that funeral yesterday and you could
tell that he's looking at him going it's
I also want to be in hospice well it's
it's rough knowing that that's right
what's right around the corner you know
what I mean like it's it's rough taking
seeing it and have being confronted with
cuz cuz deep down he knows right he
knows that's that's well he's got the
dementia Shuffle going on FKS he's not
getting better right he's say TR a
congressman he yeah earlier today yeah
he said something like TR his Christmas
tree fell over it's a sign that everyone
thinks he can't make it including the
universe there were even reports early
on after Christmas tree though after
October 7 symbol of his administration
it's not great that um that Biden was
confusing Hamas and Russia and like the
Israel Ukraine situations he's been he's
tired confusing Ukraine and Iraq for
years UK it's hard to keep these things
straight especially can't remember
anything on what was going on because he
would say why would Putin do that and
they're like Putin didn't invade Israel
like how would he do that come on man we
got a bomb all these other countries in
the
way and it's and it's just bad it's just
so bad but you know it's the one thing
that's sad to me is that you know I look
at the Republican party and you know you
look at uh a guy like Ronda Sanz who at
one point what I think everyone
considered to be just a rising star
someone who had an incredibly bright
future and then you look at these guys
like I said before like Lil Marco like
Scott
Walker um you know Tim Ryan um Tim pente
um toaw remember anyone remember toaw
you guys even know what I'm talking
about right there all these Young Guns
out there who were going to be like the
next era parent to the party that are
just complete no buies now and it's like
good job dude like you decided to troll
yourself this was a conversation I kept
hearing from a lot of people I think I
remember Ben Pier saying in particular
like with the santis they said either
you run now or you lose your moment you
don't know that the momentum will be
there in four years and I think that
tactic scares a lot of people into bad
position thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
800m and become a member over at
timcast.net all next
time